president and vice president of the
united states
his history making in every risk in so
many respects
yesterday on wednesday we celebrated the
one week since the inauguration
in that one week president biden
starting on day one president biden and
vice president
harris have driven a bold agenda
for progress and for justice
issuing transformative executive actions
ranging from crushing the corona virus
equity racial equity in so many ways
and again addressing the climate crisis
legislatively those are executive orders
legislatively
we have been working i'm very proud of
our committees who are
diligently working on the coronavirus
release legislation
as a basis for reconciliation should
that be needed
we will pass a reconciliation bill
under leadership in our house of john
yarmouth mr
sanders in the senate we'll pass a
reconciliation bill
if we need it we would hope that we
would have bipartisan
cooperation to meet the needs of the
american people
in terms of their health in terms of
distribution and equitable way
of the vaccine continue with testing
tracing treatment etc
but also to meet their economic needs
so we would hope that but we're not
taking any tools off the table
should they not while our
our committees are advancing this uh
reconciliation legislation
at the same time the executive actions
continue
today's executive action will open up
the aca's
enrollment period and take additional
steps to expand health care
we're very excited about that because of
course we're in the middle of the
pandemic
and we see this as a matter of life and
death but very different
from the trump administration who fought
the affordable care act still
still don't have the verdict from the
supreme court
to destroy the lifeline for affordable
quality health care
for all americans so we're very excited
about that particular health care
initiative today
in addition to the others that the
president has put forth in relationship
to the coronavirus again
again we are preparing for the
impeachment well we have impeached the
president
but we're preparing for the case i'm
very proud
of our managers led by jamie raskin
our distinguished array of managers
working very hard they continue to
prepare
for a trial before 100 jurors members of
the united states
senate this trial is about the
protection of the constitution
and the preservation of our republic we
will insist upon the integrity
and fairness of the proceedings
recognizing the role
that the senate plays in all of this no
one is above the law
not even a president of the united
states and trump must be tried and
convicted
to ensure that no future president will
ever think
it's okay to incite insurrection
to stop the ascertainment of who the
next president of the united states will
be
by falsely inflaming people
falsely about the outcome of the
election
in that regard in terms of security
security security which is
what we do protect and defend the
constitution security
protect the american people our very
first responsibility
and when they come to the capitol
whether to work as a legislator a
staffer
a journalist whatever we want people to
be safe
later today i'll be meeting with general
honore
russell honore who's leading a security
review of the capitol complex
updates on the timing scope and details
will be forthcoming uh protecting the
capital
is a matter of protecting our democracy
and the house will not be distracted or
delayed
from our work that we are doing again to
crush the virus
to meet the economic needs of the
american people
and to do so in a way that is fair and
just
any questions yes ma'am madam speaker i
wanted to ask you about marjorie taylor
green how concerned are you
about her past post remarks rhetoric um
what would you like to see done about
her
what i'm concerned about is the
republican leadership in the house of
representatives
who was willing to overlook ignore
of those statements
assigning her to the education committee
when she has marked
the killing of little children
at sandy hook elementary school when she
has
mocked the killing of teenagers in high
school
at the marjory stoneman douglas high
school
what could they be thinking or is
thinking too generous a word
for what they might be doing it's
absolutely appalling
and i think that the focus has to be
on the republican leadership of this
house of representatives
for the disregard they have for the
death of those children
they not only are they not interested in
gun safety and gun violence prevention
by passing legislation
for background checks legislation which
is overwhelmingly supporting a
bipartisan way in the country
but to have someone who would mock call
it a fake
if those fake events onto the
is just beyond
it's just beyond any understanding of
any regard
that the house republicans would have
for the house of representatives for the
congress of the united states
and for the heartbreak of the families
in sandy hook and at marjory stoneman
high school it really emerged from
douglas high school
it's really beyond the pale you're just
going to have to ask them
why they thought that that raised itself
to the ele uh
level of something appropriate to do in
the congress of the united states
yes sir some sort of clarity on the
stimulus are you going to bring a budget
resolution next week
bring a budget resolution to the floor
next week and then it will send it over
to the senate
then if they change it then we'll take
it back and address it by by the end of
the week
uh we will be finished with the budget
resolution
which will be about reconciliation if
needed
i hope we don't need it but if needed we
will have it one more question
manipulation issue that's going down on
wall street right now
well i understand interesting isn't um i
understand that the administration is
taking a look the
sec is taking a look at what that is
um but uh we'll all be reviewing it but
but interesting it's interesting yeah a
completely different you had two
questions
that was not considered a follow-up
would you say
yes sir um just to call on security
you've had
30 plus members of the house send you
and and uh the minority leader a letter
asking for more money for security you
have members who
are worried about not only their their
safety of capital but when they go back
to their home districts
uh you have a member uh who has talked
about
executing you uh there's and you've got
a security bulletin yesterday from dhs
about ongoing domestic violence threats
what are you saying to your members
about protecting themselves and and what
can be done to
for them to feel safe well first of all
i appreciate the letter from the members
but most of the questions
the items on their list have already
been done
perhaps they were not aware and i take
responsibility
for them not being aware in terms of use
of their mra funds
and some of the other issues that are in
there today when i meet with general
honore
he is looking at members here
members at home and in between
so we want to have a scientific
approach to how we protect members
i do believe and i have said this all
along that we will probably need a
supplemental
uh for uh more security for members
when the enemy is within the house of
representatives
a threat that members are concerned
about in addition to what is happening
outside but i think that again what's in
that letter
but just a matter of communicating to
them that has been done
the mra the rest of that i do think
though
that while they it's appropriate that
they use their mra for their security
they shouldn't have to because that
money is there for them to meet the
needs of their constituents
in the meantime uh to protect themselves
and their constituents when they
communicate with them that that is
confidential
private and not uh provocative
but then also for us to have and that's
what will be looking at
recommendations from general honore will
have some
interim report today and then he'll
continue
his work as we go forward but it's very
important
you've been the subject of threats that
comes with the job of being speaker many
of your members
not necessarily some of them feel like
they're targets now
what do you say to your your your caucus
to your fellow house members
well what we're saying is that we're
going to approach it
in a way that will truly protect them
that the issues they raised in their
letter
have by and large been in effect
so they may be relieved to hear that
they'll be hearing also
from the sergeant arms today who will
and you'll see his letter
talking about how their further
uh their protection is uh further
enhanced by certain
initiatives that were taken and as i
said
general honore is looking to see what
really
will work in terms of their service here
their service home their transportation
in between
but i call to your attention the
sergeant-at-arms letter because they'll
be more
specific about air marshals etc
but this is very very important it
shouldn't be
it shouldn't be that not only
is the president of the united states
inciting an insurrection
but keeps fanning the flame endangering
uh the the security of members of
congress
to the point that they're even concerned
about members in the house of
representatives
being a danger to them
what exactly did you mean that the enemy
is within what exactly
it means that we have members of
congress who want to bring guns on the
floor and have threatened
uh violence on other members of congress
yes sir madam speaker do you believe
that the president
can get a fair and complete trial that
lasts only one week
of course of course and that's what our
system is about
i don't know how long it will take it
depends on
the uh response that he will make but
it will be uh a fair trial and
respectful of the role that the senate
plays now that it goes
over to there yah do yes sir madam
speaker on lgbtq issues the president
campaigned on signing the equality
act into law within his first 100 days
in office
when will you hold a vote on the
legislation where i thank you for that
question this is such an exciting
piece of legislation for us we passed it
in the last congress no success in the
senate went to
mitch mcconnell's graveyard the grim
reaper
but i'm optimistic about it because i do
think we will get strong bipartisan
support
in the house and in the senate we're
working with mr cecilini the author of
the bill
for when we will roll it out with him
and
mr merkley the senator and uh
and and then we will again
uh calendar it will be it's an early
priority for us
hr5 and again
it it's about ending discrimination i'm
very pleased with what president
biden has done so far especially pleased
about eliminating the prohibition on
uh trans people from serving in the
military
that too i think was a triumph for
decency and
justice in our and our country but
uh some other initiatives that he took
about contracting and this or that
it's really it it's amazing that we
wouldn't even have to do such things
but we're particularly proud of the
equality act because it's so
comprehensive
and again ending discrimination in the
workplace and
every other aspect of life
not only is good for the lgbtq community
for our whole society but also for the
businesses that want the very best they
should be hiring uh without any
concern of complaint uh about the
the the diversity that they are
introducing into there is that's why we
think we'll have strong bipartisan
support
we think the business community will
help us
in the senate yeah one more
no i said thank you madam yes sir do you
believe that
you say reconciliation is is a backstop
that you'd rather have a bipartisan bill
but you're you're it sounds like you're
not you're not
optimistic that that will happen that is
that a correction
we have to be ready i do think
that we have more leverage getting
cooperation on the other side if they
know we have an alternative
as well but i would think if we're
talking about
additional funding for vaccines to be uh
just
and they're just not in production but
their distribution if we're talking
about putting money into the pockets
of the american people with the direct
payments
if we're talking about supporting state
and local government
so that they're able to implement all
these things
open our schools our health care workers
our police and fire first responders
our teachers our teachers our teachers
transportation sanitation
food workers i would hope that the
republicans would be supportive of that
many of the localities that will benefit
have
have republican mayors and republican
county executives
so i would hope that that we would be
able to do it
in a bipartisan way and again
i said if there's an argument that needs
to be made to people
that we need more funding for the
vaccines more distribution
uh resources more of the
vials and syringes and all that make it
happen
uh i think many of the republicans would
be supportive of that and i hope so
but we cannot not have it happen
we have to act and that that is why i
said
we want it to be bipartisan always but
we can't uh surrender if they're not
going to be doing that
instead we will pass it thank you all
dangerous
from the house manager you need should
vice president mike pence come
testifying